une production du studio sf bio sans
filtre le podcast on parle de convaincre
nos invités ben si tu me plante le
podcast semaine et présenté par benjy d
everyday mais je n'ai vu des cds
boissons dtc des boissons de tout le
temps en fait parce que c'est jour de
plage à tous les jours de l'année et
sangria des vins blancs des vins rosés
des drinks saveurs tropicales vraiment
tout votre gamme de produits alcoolisés
pour célébrer à chaque jour de l'année
comme si c'était le début d un jour de
plage aller dans les couche-tard aller
dans les épiceries vous allez trouver ce
partout puis on n'a pas le code promo
rien juste aller à les tripes et avec
l'habitude et everyday sur ce cette
semaine alors il se servait dans nurse
ulises en adoptant tu connais qui a été
notre première invitée est vrai au
podcast qui qui qui est tous lancé cette
aventure le avec nous au fait que l'on
doit une quand même puis on est vraiment
content de retrouver plus tard après un
énorme voyage qu'elle fait un west durée
cette mesure qui s'imposait pas l'enfant
dans sa vie c'était un pack castrais
personnel comme vous avez pu comme on
pouvait s'en douter suffisante qui qui
qui est une personne qui s'exposent
qu'avant sur les réseaux sociaux de
partage sa vie fait qu on a discuté de
son voyage en discuter de ces relations
de sa relation de couple avec son
nouveau copain
c'est devenu quand même assez émotionnel
dans le podcast pour je pense après il
faut qu'il y ait des larmes sera pas le
cas - un groupe solide sans fil puis
mais c'était un peu de cash
principalement par touches à moi je
pense que je voulais passer un beau un
bon moment puis j'ai l'impression que
vous allez vous allez mais c'est aussi
vous avez été touchés comme comme nous
on a été sans aucun doute cette annonce
rapidement d'un petit mois non violence
et un nouveau podcast qui s'appelle le
sans filtre vip qui est disponible sur
nos pétrone en fait disponible en
nommant détruit en seulement ou est ce
qu on rencontre des gens qui sont un
petit peu moins connus du public mais
qui sont tout autant tout aussi
intéressant que les invités sans filtre
le concept est le même on s'assoit puis
engeance date site
dernièrement on a reçu louis fournier
qui mon âge est aussi l'agent d'une
coupe d'influenceurs web avant une
discussion autour de tout et de rien
avec ces gens là donc ça vous intéresse
vous êtes avides de podcasts puissance
marzouki est en train de dire
j'imagine que vous l'êtes fait que le
lien vers notre pays on va dans la
description de cette vidéo si sinon très
importante si vous écoutez ça en mode
audio seulement de commenter surtout sur
l'application balado j'ai une collation
dernièrement sur l'algorithme ça nous
aide énormément
si vous commandez vos impressions sur
l'application balado simuler sa rétine
des cinq étoiles ça fait un énorme bout
de chemin
puis sinon sans plus attendre bompas de
caste bonne écoute
[Musique]
les angles bon retour
jacques est un rêve mais je pense que ça
commence exactement moi même la première
mais au moins que c'est essayer der
merwe deuxième fois ok pas sur un an sur
le micro 2 et la dame avec nous dit
comment ça va ça va très bien comment
parler
tout a commencé avec taux à 10 ans non
mais pauvre et on attend de sa star tu
es fort vraiment un gros push surtout
qui tient à pression on est ensuite allé
je pense le deuxième dans le cadre d un
gros push sur youtube peu après
seulement neuf attaques et ça se
reposant rencontre des influenceurs mais
on les aime tout autant talaga n'y avait
pas de casque chez moins fiable je
laisse aux gens de le plaisir de cd
musical
on en parle sujet franchement nous de
laterrière espace et en libye les boss
j'espère que c'est pas moi et c'est ça
ouais j'avoue aurait pensé il ya quand
même juste une chance sur 46 ce soit
vous puissiez la discussion était
intéressante à ce prix que ça le soit
pas ce qui se passe sur les 46 personnes
sont venues seules pas caché pas quel
point un homme qui écoute le podcast je
suis passé colle pour sarah pagin au
ladakh au dessus non pas quatre chars
n'est qu'une course depuis que c'est ce
qui au quai ouest est-ce que selon vous
est-ce que je parle a man's womb kiev le
46e lane
je pense que vous voyez et c'est aussi
une évolution de toutes les dents ma
tête dans mon corps m'a mise dans tout
le jeu me sens bien je me sens vraiment
vraiment envie j'étais pas que j'étais
pas bien dollars bien préparés parce que
je trouve que tu as l'air vraiment bien
c'est clair
toi tu t'es entraîné beaucoup quand on
voyage ouais mais c'est odm et même je
partais des fois mettons cap est dans
une espèce de vos rêves de voyage prend
les habitudes que tu tiens pas quand tu
reviens mais l'autre sans ail souvent
écolo fitness wii minutes à pied c'est
vraiment chiant trop loin mais une
chance que le champ est là pour faire
que j'ai par exemple parce que ce qui
est ce qui fait que je veux c'est pas
mal lui en tiens tiens un moment donné
ont voyagé pendant une semaine il y
avait mal en coup fait qu' à l'époque
j'étais j'ai pas encore été dit sur ce
qui me stresse
j'espère que je veux pas perdre ce qu'un
kiosque en ali ça serait poche que mes
bonnes habitudes soit passée à cause de
quelqu'un fait qu'il faut que je me
motive à y aller
il planifié s'en aller ou une personne
est le il vraiment flou il n'y a pas
encore de billets
htc ace qui est ce qu'on peut dire que
c'est un job oui oui on peut dire ça
cool
la saq a effectué lui vient d'où mais
d'irlande tacle éventuellement ils vont
retourner voir sa famille un peu plus de
sa fin huit enfants il est en attente on
demande depuis ben attentivement entre
quand ils voyagent depuis un an
glee a fait l'afrique l'asie qui le sait
sa première fois en amérique du nord
je ne m'abuse de cuite encore en mode de
voyage
ouais mais là c'est quand même une pause
pour lui le non sens que tu es montréal
ça reste west wing country fait c'est
plus c'est vraiment plus relax que
l'asie puis il y avait besoin aussi de
parce que pour ouvrir la fin de notre
voyage
on voyait une plage c'est comment ils
n'ont plus dépassé 6 2 qui s'est rendu
qui a été plus impressionné notre
système comme c'était le temps qu'on
revienne que je revienne qui lui aussi
syfy vient de s'asseoir sur ses fesses
puis de travail et puis une petite
routine et je me lève le matin j'ai mon
petit café chez ma petite vaisselle la
soirée une pige à stx est le fun c'est
vraiment d'avoir une petite routine
aujourd'hui je jamais j'aurais été gérée
penser que je suis dit est-ce que tu
allais mais se ruer dessus que la route
mais c'est ce que ça fait quinze ans de
peau c'est moi mettons avec ma vie de
musicien wever quand j'ai une couple de
jours à maison où est ce que je peux
faire je me lève le matin marc au jam je
fais mes titres lafarge du temps mais
cuisine et les doutes mais moi je vais
plus au jim vraiment je fais la course
et la natation
touati bourget bougez vous moi je veux
ça fait deux ans que j'ai commencé le
crossfit away fait que wembley ça
mélangé prime pour moi que j'arrêterais
pour dire comment cette semaine 6 9 mais
oui c'est vraiment brûlante je me rends
compte que j'ai tout le temps fatigué
puis que c'était probablement un peu
sous le titre fait que je fais tout le
temps vraiment claqué tout et que je
pense le fait que c'est du crossfit
c'est parce que
le somail à ce moment il ya les hippies
pomme poussé au point qu'ils ont envie
de vomir mais sert à cela on dirait que
l'été comme dans le moment facture voter
fake c'est sûrement moi aussi qu'il faut
qu'ils apprennent à commun j'ai rêvé
mais en même temps l'été c'est le fun
est d'ailleurs fait que je cours chez
l'énergie dow jones en extérieur moi
j'essaie de profiter plus du soleil les
parents qui le dit mais tout est en
ruine
non mais et oui c'est ça
roy y avoir une routine men et ouais
c'est ça fait du bien à ce type oui s
est organisée dans cette affaire
ça peut être faire des petites choses
mais manger bouger ses seuls voyages
c'est de séparer serment de voile
ailleurs mais c'est de revenir chez vous
avec tout ce que tu avais tu construis
lie de chez vous m'aidez construit le
futur découvre un peu chez vous je peux
ça fait sens maman tu revois tes amis
sûrs redécouvre cette espèce de de ville
de montreuil en voyage c'est loin des
gens qui connaissent des réflexes qui
connaissent c'est dans ce sens que j'ai
on a catégorisé dans le plus la fille
trash qui boit trop piquée du doré
jusqu'à deux ans d'après midi le temps
record be in peace eux je me suis aussi
de donner ces qualificatifs le en
voulant être honnête avec ce que je suis
ou à l'erreur j'ai un peu poussé la note
1 appropriant sait si ces défis j'en ai
fait un arbre ending mais s'amenuisait
beaucoup parce que je n'étais pas
capable d'évoluer puis les gens autour
de moi ben il m'associer à ceux affectés
ces termes en avait six exemples c'est à
dire jusqu'à 2 heures d'après mon chèque
doit être loin ça permet de séparer un
peu de la cua très attaché moi c'est
l'image que les gens de toit puis de
retrouver
ouais juste toi de la version wii
vraiment c'est sûr que là il ya
l'internet qui me gardaient
c'était pas mal moins je trouve pas
moins active que tu l'étais ici ouais
c'est de te semble éloigner un peu
c'était moins actif sur les publications
les story je suis quand même beaucoup de
partager les moments où ce que je voyais
mais c'était moins de blabla parce que
tu as mangé moins toi coucher son jeu
qui fait qu'elle a su revenir sa force
et accessoires mais ça fait bien puis un
bon sept mois de m'éloigner des
déconstruit que je m'étais fait mieux
sur un nu pieds facto plus envie de
cette personne là dans le fond ça l'est
encore partie survenue qu'ils commencent
à être touchés revenais chez l'habitant
le matin c'était mon réveil je m'ennuie
proches de 11,6 des jeux points encore
en jeu pour me changer au complet mais
je rajoute les trucs que je rajoute des
trucs a mis le corps à travers sa tête
est parti pour une semaine au début m en
fait j'ai exposé partir pour une
retraite de yoga alors que tout bateau
turc qui baisse c'est une retrait de
yoga québécoise en a une fille que si
c'était juste des québécois qui était
dessus statut un contrôle des toits qui
avait décidé d'y aller par toi même
personnellement je ne passais pas le
yoga je n'aime pas ça me fait chi chaud
selon pilate
mais je savais que jamais parce que j'ai
fait on garde d'une semaine qui c'est
une opportunité dont la seule chose que
j'avais payé seulement bien l'avion
effectifs chez camp mais la crise une
semaine on savait malade je pensais plus
au pays en examen mais c'est que j'ai
dit oui finalement le yoga c'est pas le
yoga en soi que j'ai émis s'était jetée
avec du monde un peu tout va et claudine
langlois qui est une fille très est
connecté à ses chakras un peu hippie ou
trois pièces dans le sens je me suis
laissé emporter là dedans puis jetée
comme je lé vécu avec elle
jouer je le prendrais si j'ai pas fait
comme tel avec l'ouverture d'esprit
complète puis je pas revenue et en me
disant bon mais chaque race ont pas
l'union ce moment vraiment pas mais j'ai
ça m'a fait du bien de me laisser
embarquer là dedans puis de les autres
choses puis j'en avais besoin d'une
certaine façon
puis après ma deuxième journée j'ai
appelé le moment de la maison sheets je
m'excuse je relie pau je sais pas
combien de temps la deuxième j'avais
déjà je savais que je revenais pas ouais
j'ai appelé mon monde puisse et comme je
suis désolé je ne sais pas pourquoi je
sais pourquoi crèche par nazis puis j'ai
le goût d'être le plus longtemps mais je
voulais pas revenir c'était pas le choix
dit elle avoir besoin de rester plus
longtemps
ouais mais c'est pas la première fois je
fais seule je fais tout le temps
surchargé je disposais pas retirer une
semaine à élire trois ans puis je partis
trois mois faire le tour des autres
unités c'était pas mon avance n'est pas
ma première fois je faisais ça mon était
pas sur celui d'un patron qui serait peu
moins fait que c'est ce qui je savais
pas combien de temps j'allais rester
j'avais pages à l'aller ou s'il allait
rester ou juste une semaine de plus il
faut faire ça a fini par sept mois ci
oui c'est bien quand tu étais venu la
première fois de parler d'un dicton
fantasme c'est être brûler ta maison
puis danse dans ce genre de comportement
laisse c'est tellement tort de pouvoir
le lien entre ces idées-là de dire un
mot rien tu accumules des choses dans
ton dans ta vie puis tu viens espèce de
marez d avoir accumulé 200 civils de
quitter sa cellule
tu parle maintenant de l'image qui était
attribué de ton monde au québec ta
relation au québec aussi
puis pilote de neufs d'avoir l'envié de
jeu ce soir au quai refresh que 3,9
refresh la page j'ai pas lui faire tout
en même temps si j'ai pas fait comme
bail je me suis pas de détacher du
québec
tout de suite ça c'est fait un mois à
foix quitté évidemment je me suis pas
détaché du québec lui laisse pressentir
une issue encore oui je m'aime bien le
meilleur endroit
peu importe sa planète le québec fait le
meilleur jeudi serait la meilleure ville
très grande fan de notre de notre place
si je mens à l'excès ouais ça s'est fait
progressivement le détachement bercy
mais c'était facile parce que j'avais
besoin était mais ça peut s'il s'agit
pas marcher à faire ça c'est sûr je
voulais depuis vraiment longtemps qu'ils
étaient survenus piste et cela je me
suis débarrassé de tout mon linge il pas
le goût de riz m je me je remarque je
mets les mêmes aux affaires que j'avais
en voyage à jour mais maintenant les
vieilles affaires que j'avais un sac à
dos tu avais un cercle
je suis parti avec un sac à dos sam
sommes une vie pas de poche en ratant un
sac à dos contenant un sac gratuite
d'une nouvelle mise à jour 18 non pas
que j'avais ce qui avait mis au monde
mon petit mon petit linge d'une semaine
finalement je me suis débarrassé de la
moitié de ce que j'avais et j'ai tout
racheter puis mon ami qui était avec moi
à la retraite de yoga est là revenez au
québec et non c'est pas vrai on est
parti en thaïlande
e.on a fait l'inde en somme un but elle
est partie en thaïlande les rejoint
thaïlande qui après ce après un beau
temps talent de leur venue au québec
qu'à me laisser son nom ça qui était
elle avait un gros gros liste de cinq
voyages mais le même sac de tout cas tu
mets en avant au japonais mais c'est
enfin fait que mon sept mois je les
passais avec son petit sac à elpy monde
sac samsung chacun sur une épaule c'est
fou ça doit c'était doit remettre en
perspective vraiment beaucoup
l'importance que tu accordes ou matériel
ben c'est pas que j'aime pas un matériel
c'est que maintenant je le choisis
maintenant j'ai pas besoin de beaucoup
de bijoux
j'ai besoin de sebha glock ma chaîne qui
me font sentir bien c'est choisir les
morceaux qui me font fait que j'ai
encore si j'aime c'est encore le linge
les bijoux à l'erreur met en place d'
accumuler plein d'affaires que j'aime
pas vraiment j'ai je me concentre sur
les petites affaires qui me font fortune
100 serbe et puis que j'aime les portes
et fake c'est encore du bla bla pour
gosses mais simon cocorico corse
c'est quoi ces maris condos l'espèce de
show à netflix japonaise qui grignotent
je m'appelle pas c'est quoi mais à
komarom des maisons puis à claire le
stock le faut que tu prennes chaque
pièce est ce que sa maman
la réponse est non dans des bars à ce
que je l'utilisé la dent dernières
années il m'a tenté les enfants qui
trinquent
ça peut servir même s'il porte jamais
porté sur ses gardes
c'est les capsules sur la décroissance
qui attira de fait ces iem c'est là
dedans il y avait une fille qui parle et
c'est comme un défi pour désencombrer sa
maison c'est comme qui première journée
du mot tu débarrassions d'affaires les
journées deux enfants entre devenait
trop d'enfants et à fin du mois ça fait
comme 400 enfants et 400 system tic que
tu veux de l'été puis au début ça ma
première journée une affaire dont ça se
fait mais quinze enfants ça n'est pas
dégoûté par jean rouch je sais même pas
si j'ai 400 à fin mai mais c'est
intéressant je t'aime tellement la fin
qu'on consomme on sait qu'ils sont que
n'importe quoi je revenais dans ma
chambre
si j'ai des sacs grumman le make up que
j'ai jamais utilisées et que je sais
pertinemment que j'ai jamais utilisé un
outil dédié à faire que j'avais il ya
quatre ans et des vieux rouge à lèvres
que jusqu'au mont cause où j'ai le goût
de m couleurs l'allemande anni non
j'aime pas ça le move for me babines moi
je mettrais pas pourquoi je garde les
caves
oui que la liberté qu'après ce que cela
procure faire justement là ses voyages
le tilt et comment à quel point tu veux
sentir libre c'est ça ça absolue
si vous ou tu veux quand tu veux non
mais non mais ça une raison quest un
cliché nous sépare c'est vrai qui truste
appelle des libertés le cloud
il y avait quelque chose ici qui faisait
que tu avais le goût de vivre
je ne pense pas que je pense pas que
c'était moi je ne sais pas ma routine
faudrait ce que je dis je sais pas je
marque aston et réfléchi je pense que
six mois que j'aimais plus j'ai pu bien
moi j'en chie
est ce que tu as pu bien avec toi dans
ta tête dans la position que un peu des
deux je pense ça se rejoindre dans le
sens que mieux qu'une entente est mieux
que gère ton environnement haute et j'ai
commencé encore j'en parle encore je
fais du ménage je fais du ménage avec
ton pote tu sais pas moi ce que je sais
pas je tiens à y jeter ailleurs je sais
pas tu es ce puits je sais pas comment
l'expliquer ben je l'expliquerai bien
trou jusqu'à maintenant
fc sète semble avoir comme russe est
organisée je sais pas comment demain
c'est moins de suspense que le fait que
j'ai compris que je pouvais peut-être
parce que tu dis que tu peux te détacher
des affaires mais tentez pas partie
longtemps avec vraiment rien
le thé comme sur vimeo qui je peux pour
vrai à voir qu'à petite chouette ça va
être correct je me vois survivent avec
une fois que tu le fais pour être comme
un kilo c'est vrai je peux m'en
débarrasser puis je les fais tu là
bon d'accord et encore une coupe des
t-shirts que je garde pour complet pas
d'enjeu du jour et nuit un pied puis là
dedans c'est quand on rencontre riche en
dans ton voyage
j'allais rencontrer la première journée
il était en retraite des urnes ont
manqué est arrivé
à la retraite de yoga et j'arrive à la
retraite de yoga et j'ai jti macdonald à
william servat soul et sa plage on vient
d'arriver goffette qui compense la plage
on s'est torché cac 40 ans que ma
chambre
ah oui là dessus j'ai surgi prix les
bains des choses puis le jeter avait que
deux mille amis non l'océan et puis j'ai
vu hagondange et au loin et j'ai attaqué
ce blond à quoi même pas quoi mais c'est
ph
[Rires]
j'ai juste un match mais pas game
l'appli pas jeter sur pierre fait comme
crier alors j'ai gueulé de quoi pire
nous voilà ce que tu dis fuck et non
parce que ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'ils baptisent juste attirés par
d'autres mondes à ce moment là dans ma
vie c'était correct de la fait pas faute
parce que je sais pas en amour avec
encore liz lui tu es un gars que je
croise un ami je saute et je pensais pas
plus loin que seul notre m
toujours samedi sexe la date est rien
lima le fait que je me suis pas sentie
mal je sais pas et puis les feelings
c'est arrivé vite nécessairement et puis
je te dis à ce moment de la vie qu'est
ce qui se faisait par le temps est ce qu
est ce que aujourd'hui tu sais ce que c
est ce que tu sais ce que c'est mais
n'entendent que tout cas je me suis
préparé à ça j j'ai pensé beaucoup en
sachant que ça lui revient sur le sujet
puis je sais pas prêtes on en parlait ce
réseau je me suis fait demander beaucoup
puis pas répondu parce que je sais pas
quoi dire j'ai pas j'ai peur que on est
en couple exclu l'excusé est exclusif
est ce que c'est un concept qui toi te
fait part d'une certaine façon août à 40
ans ne connaissent même toi même te
connaissant pas moi de connaissances toi
mais toi tu connais sans toi toi sachant
que commenter comment tu sais ça parce
que ce que j'avais peur pourquoi j'avais
peur de le dire c'est que j'avais peur
que ça c'est ça enlève la valeur à ce
que j'avais avec jean-michel j'avais
vraiment peur de le dire
puis parce que jean-michel ayew c'est
normal et apprendre j'ai gardé de bd
est remisée dans l'eau je m'excuse non
non plus ici à aucun moment de se
prendre un peu son propos on n'est pas
sûr au poids non plus ce serait prendre
les esprits mme s'installant mais c'est
tout à fait normal je comprends ce que
tu faisais depuis jamais du moins nous
on va penser que de progresser dans dans
ton raisonnement dans la façon que tu
vois la vie enlève quoi que ce soit la
façon de te vécu la vie avance ça a rien
à voir vraiment c'est juste quelqu'un
qui change pas son attitude face à à la
vie face aux relations pas
nécessairement positifs tout le temps
toutes les relations des dynamiques sont
différentes aussi c'est qu'ils
s'installent tranquillement tpiy qui
chacun puisse au pit il y en a qui ont
différentes modèles de coûts qui sont
heureux puis le dans nos moments de leur
vie avec une autre personne sur notre
modèle d'essai ces six corps étaient des
riches qui a une diversité là dans
quelle mesure cette façon de vivre sa
vie pis si ce titre leur nouvelle
relation il ya une dynamique s'est
installée puis en laissant de parler
tout soutenu que les deux étaient mieux
la station le tpiy comme si chaque
relation vraiment différente pitt et
chaque relation compose de personnes
fixe le mixer un ajustement de deux
personnes très jeunes pour lui si
mettons y embrasser une autre fille pour
lui ça veut dire que ces émotions il ya
des émotions c'est lui et pas c'est et 6
aussi dans le sens que si mes temps jean
michel
pour cheikh kane je sais même pas grave
parce que certainement un petit peu
grave genre on s'aime enfin la journée
tchèque en votant par l'obr autour d'une
guerre c'est correct
cishan fait sur ça veut dire quitte en
amour avec quelqu'un d'autre
oui c'est ça lui notre intention fait
que c'est lui la façon qu'ils voient
mettons la sexualité où le couple c'est
un autre mon pied je dis pas que jean mi
mai le fait comprendre clairement que ce
n'est pas un modèle qui aiment et non
plus mais je pense que par amour
i il vivait pareil qui est sa place de
maître pied ça tapis en même temps je
suis pas en train de dire que j'ai pas
une centrale d'engagement douter que ce
n'est pas l'idéal pour lui je savais toi
tu sais d'un dans l'état d'esprit que tu
étais à ce moment là est ce que je me
trompe si je dis que si lui avait mis sa
limitless arrêt juste signifier la fin
de la relation probablement c'est ce
probablement et je pense qu'ils savaient
pitt s'était pas ouvert vers ce n'est
pas clair temps on faisait nos règles de
couple au fur et à mesure qu'ils que ça
allait puis c'est parce que notre
première rencontre en hippie moi il m'a
montré son pénis mais maman tous en
pénitence noté genre ok on est entre une
vidéo de ce nom mais on va partir comme
s'ils avaient joué quand c'est ce que je
vais écrire c'est intense mais sa partie
de même une approbation c'était comme on
se disait quel point qu'on croyait pas
sur les coupes gens n'y avait pas être
blanc d'avoir moi je te sa première
petite copine y avait eu des offres des
histoires
mais ce fait qu on est on ne sait partis
là-dessus on était des chaumes c'était
mon meilleur ami chambre mon amoureux
mais c'est pas mon meilleur ami dans le
sens il y oppose d'affaires le de ces
différences si j'étais pas que l'un est
meilleur que l'autre
j'ai l'impression que j'en dis moi c'est
beaucoup plus simple c'est beaucoup plus
balancer mais j'ai envie c'était mon
ride or die le système testé mon
meilleur tome janry qu est ce que c est
ce que dans ta relation maintenant ce
que tu sens est ce que tu sens 100%
épanouie dans ce même si ce je m'en
aller 1 1 je pense que le fait que ça
tellement mal fini je voulais plus
seulement celles émises il s'était
c'était tout le temps une game le savoir
c'est quoi la limite est ce qu'on dit
c'est merci fokine beaucoup tester si on
était constamment blessé mais en même
temps c'est ce qui rend des six était
passionné jeu tout en vous en avait
parlé avec lui c'est assez passionné pis
si ça fait que chance et relaxé faute de
relaxe puis sami pas arrivé une fois de
c'est pas vrai au début il ya un
ajustement
je n'ai pas tout de suite aux liens
exclusivité exclusivité je vais être
honnête que j'ai eu un petit doute que
je me gênerai pas pour texter de mon
billet je pense que son on a eu des
ajustements
plus de faire comprendre que ça pouvait
pas fonctionner comme symbole des gros
tort que le pied ehrhoff au début
dallier de vision qui est il
vous avez trouvé comment fonctionner
mais je me sens pas dans un but et ma
vision c'est ce talent ils ont subi
quasiment y ont pris conscience était
c'était comme un on se manquer de
respect là dedans c'est lui il ya les
dénigrer ma façon de voir ça comme si
c'était pas possible de mm
qui mange c'est comme sérieux qui risque
était fermé d'esprit je suis comme
voyons dont le spawn même ça marche
c'est dans ma tête était comme mais pour
lui c'est un couple c'est même ça
marchait très bien cohabiter des
relations ça varie de 10 onu le gros
chien puis on a fini par comprendre d'où
on venait puis ensuite trouvé un petit
milieu qui reste plus que l'exclusivité
mais dans beaucoup de respect et d'amour
pied il n'y a pas une fois où met-on
sortie d'un bar j'ai le goût de fraise
une toilette est ce que je trouve que
c'est quand on dit on a trouvé un milieu
est ce que tu penses que le milieu est
plus de sa vision à lui et oui oui
clairement si on sentait qu on s'entend
que la concession était faite par toi
plus que aussant est un compromis qui
quitte ce la fin auxerre
je pensais que ça va être plus dur que
ce qui est offert pour qui me stressait
beaucoup d'en parler de cette histoire
c'est que quand j'ai annoncé notre
rupture j'ai dit j'espère qu'il va
trouver quelque chose qui lui convient
mieux j'espère que je trouve quelque
chose qui me convient aussi
puis c'est à ce moment là dans ma tête
ça voulait dire une relation
complètement ouverte
c'est je m'imaginais que sa lecture
l'autoport que les gens aient enfin ou
qui pensent que ce pas je l'aimais passé
ou que c'était si poster gens me feel
man c'était différent c'était autre
chose puis jetée dans une place dans ma
tête rouge c'était autre chose je ne
sais pas j'ai en ce moment oui justin de
mon bord qui a été la concession parce
que j'avais envie d'être avec lui pisté
ce qu'il fallait que je fasse
mais je me sens pas brimer là dedans
puis il ne fait pas sentir comme si
j'associais l'exclusivité comme si ça
allait être une cage comme si ça allait
être salée brimer ma liberté mais zéro
le pire maman d'anaïs carey clermont
bojan pas grave ils vont avoir puis je
vous conseille les garder mais je veux
j'ai hérité jusqu'à ce que je dis c'est
comme système mais brille me met
vraiment pas je vis vraiment bien le
pied à limite il ya une sorte de fierté
maintenant je suis moi j'y voyais un
côté fier là dedans kg maintenant
essayer des relations qui stimule
turquie éthiques
ce que vous n'avez pas trouvé
l'équilibré toujours de tiraillements
qui on n'est jamais vraiment exactement
en bonne place le tout l'impression que
ces relations louvier comme stabilité un
équilibre que tristan juste bien c'est
pas difficile c'est pau c'est pas une
forte et constante avec jean le dernier
podcast que tu avais omis une fille
vraiment vraiment fort ce passionné de
montagne russe ne savait pas qu'il est
moins haut cette personne là dessus je
la respecte mais tout cela voudrait pas
dans mon entourage à qui je comprends à
ce moment ci et des jets d'eau j'ai
d'autres ex que c'est me faut une bonne
amie de fac ça dépend vraiment
mais maintenant tu es pas en couple avec
aux bains s'est tout récemment c'est ça
fait
tu sais donc pas ce que j'ai quand même
un gars quand même mais comment découper
les émotions passent et plus je pleurais
je les ai vus depuis les dernières
semaines
je suis son meilleur ami ouais c'est
grâce à toi non mes ouailles comme
jeanne par la nati jetant maillage
comment s'est-elle commencer ça fait
trop ce qui est du coup le genre du jeu
facile à date je suis pas aussi
j'imagine que ça m'apporte mais je sais
pas trop ce que c'est une question de
match sont approchés à la touche - pic
avec un autre site sentir et transformé
je n'ai pas de comparatif fois que je le
sais pas mais je me sens quand même à
l'ouest où j'arrive le pire est déjà
passé j'ai l'impression que ouais parce
que c'est pas juste de toits qui
m'inquiète ouais comme je connaissais
pas le cas ouais mais j'espère que je
sais mais ouais ouais c'est ça ouais
c'est ce que j'ai vu ce soir les larmes
aux yeux j'ai pleuré une grosse chute
l'autre jour j'en crois comme un bébé le
genre celle qui agite pendant que les
gens qui étaient en tout les bleus que
du mental
non j'écoutais dalphond filiale en
ukraine album ensemble de la musique
ensemble encore la musique ensemble qui
a ouais ouais comme samedi le savait pas
c'est quand même pâques a fait sentir
mais on tenait plus gros show à vif est
le jazz de montréal grosse affaire il ya
des tonnes qui parle de tout cela fait
que ça j'imagine ça va être un moment
riche en émotions 1
mais c'est un bon terme c'est pour tout
le monde parce que cela me remet sur le
besoin d'avoir une petite distance au
début pour se replacer
sinon c'est pas si longtemps semble-t-il
on a chacun nos places puis on se voit
pas le travail mais c'est ok c'est sûr
que c'est pas évident mais les deux
jours on a la volonté en tout cas de
continuer d'être en bons termes faut
travailler ensemble j'imagine qu'on est
capable de le faire fait que fixer ce
mélo john est contente et je pratiquais
layton c'est parce que pour le show qui
s'en vient pie ix en tout cas pas pepy
comme je me suis mis à boy mais quand
même faut king baby le cpie il ya
d'autres fois ticket j'aurais dû pleurer
qu'on avait des discussions piste et
c'était comme si jean un robot il essaie
comme cette fois les y est comme une
souche que fait plus pileux ses sorties
genre pendant une heure matinale et et
je comprends fallu que je l'admets
charte de course où il a couru pour moi
enfin autre chose que tel il fallait que
je m'habille les pêcheurs parce que les
policiers m'ont soutenu la guerre et n'a
pas cherché dans sa grille en asie
est-ce que c'est dans tout ce qu'un
petit labo est ce qu est ce qu il ya des
hits et parce que mettons mois de
l'extérieur il n'y a pas eu l'air
d'avoir des moments nécessairement ou
est-ce que tu t'ennuies y est difficile
mais tu eu des moments où est ce qu'ils
pensaient de moi un jardin genre de
soirée où qui était d'avoir le chu loin
qui fusent le monde je suis un cru de ma
vie honnêtement le plus dur ce qui est
deux enfants et plus tough ces câbles
mais ses bons offices lima rupture avec
jean mi melle autre affaire c'est pas ta
laquelle fischer qui veut être la
qualité des toits des trous dans le sol
tchèque - bénin tout à chier
la chine a totalisé sa touche pas à mon
show jamais loin c'est ça ma vie qui
était dessus quand la revue étais tu
étais sûr connu de ce compteur mais
parce qu'il est oui a été co leurs skis
étaient contentes qui se passe entre
spéciale est pas grave moi je lève j'ai
pas besoin de vous faire marrer pour
comme moi mais non c'est pas ta tout
seul c'était l'attachement ici que cette
revue dr otto non ce que vous parlez moi
j'ai parlé de chaque fois ce nom ah
ouais ok des applications qui faute
souffler dans une pareille pour
débloquer téléphone bon pilote s'était
dès qu'ils les bleus ou des biens qui
quitte à vexer gaulle
c'est un outil d'échangé gpac 500 hommes
et ont jailli au jam souhaite pas de
perdre c'était de l'eau que de cette
lettre sans bien six ans maintenant
non non parce que c'est pas mon est au
complet qui basé sur lui mais c'est
vraiment le dire mais côté est côté
ménages courte et comment je me sens que
ma bougie ouart et woerth est lui en ce
moment il n'en lis depuis fait ses
affaires le sujet je suis brune déloger
le doute j'ai le goût de bouger puis
totti va s'en aller je veux continuer ça
c'est clair c'est plus le jean qu'il
s'agit pas je me fasse des charmes de
jamie maggie chine ue qui parlera en
soit j'aime et c'est tombé du monde avec
qu'il faut c'est ce que quelqu'un qui
pose incluse tellement plus facile me
lever le matin marché minutes pour les
pousser de la fonte
parce que je suis moi aussi je
m'entraîne comme l'ange dans mes
entraînements si je veux privilégie les
machines que je peux tu as si je peux
tester un peuple ce que j'avais les
jambes qui avec un sentiment un peu de
côté oui je veux assad livre le pivot
fulham a fait que ça me scie le métier
j'ai appris dans le fond tu es tu
t'exposes route de nettoyage des côtes
je passe le régime c'est vraiment une
bonne place pour laisser son téléphone
dans le sac puis genre pendant une heure
et existe pas justice à la faire c'est
vraiment un cadre machine story à chaque
fois que je te hau jim ou presse
si j'oublie pas parce qu'après ça je
parlais dans mes archives pour regarder
le nombre de fois que les tours jean
dans mon mot à hu est juste pour ça je
le ferme à corus qui est dispo tas mais
aussi c'est le fait de montrer que j'ai
continué pis moi je suis fière mais la
raison principale c'est qu'ils
apprécient je peux regarder combien de
fois je t'ai laissé qu'un jet ski pays
pis j'ai vu ton before and after
impressionnant hier quelqu'un qui m'a
dit que c'était juste la position puis
c'est ça mon come around sauf quand
juste la pression j'ai regardé mes deux
vidéos parce que cdi screenshot de vidéo
mais j'ai regardé mes deux pays non je
suis chiant la mort lorsque la pollution
pour je suis vraiment fier de moi parce
que c'est comme pisser sur la vidéo ce
que je dis c'est bon aujourd'hui gens me
vient d'annoncer de son bord que c'est
officiel que c'est terminé notre
relation je me reprends ma go c'est ce
que je disais en vidéo ci dessous la
photo il dollon voilà ce que j'avais mis
ma taille thèmes - film le ton meteab a
fait en fait plutôt carré mais j - d
pour l'heure que j'avais mais non c'est
vraiment chiant
[Musique]
ouais c'est parce que je savais que si
on se laissait qu'en plus ce genre tu
tombes france est une structure en une
en pis aurait tellement été facile fait
que j'ai faite non le il faut aussi que
si au moins germe atteindre piste et
c'était comme c'est même peu j'allais
pas bien j'étais robotique mon enfance
était commun qu'ils vont faire des
affaires pour que j'aille mieux mais je
ressentais rien j'étais vide
vite vite vite fait que je m'entraîne
affiché comme non je succès à long terme
en ce moment je ressens une fois je le
fasse parce que sinon c'est trop facile
de se lever le fini par se remplir de
foule je suis en continu
juste un exemple mais encore une fois
changé pour beaucoup celui tanches et
inscrit son 30e space kidettes ou meg
fait que pour lui c'est un gros gros
complexe il se sentait pas bien d'y
abriter on parle de calmes et en janvier
certains mais c'est en train de lui
c'est il est vraiment bon là dedans pour
semaines des quartiers de quad en tête
de la poule 1 curcuma bonne grosse
expression c'est comment tu avais jamais
attendre quelques heures tandis que
maintenant que c'est tout l'inventaire
tout le crédit auto je l'utilisais fait
que ces seuils
il lui était comme bon là j'aime pas de
congé de leur fait que je travaillais
pour puis tout le monde rien peut lui
passe un gringalet réellement voilà
quelqu'un qui connaît à tahiti georges
paulin fecteau qu'avec de vue mais
tandis que tués dans l'attaqué
non non c'est complètement saoul celle
très gros comme le bras
c'est comme un lion en tout cas un autre
et ce qui m'a dit c'est je pensais juste
à l'est de notre belle comme hymne
annoncé ouais ok on est
ce n'est pas complètement défoncé le
titre n'est pas complètement défoncée tu
vois quelqu'un comble c'est ce captage
un petit bois qu'il en complément des
fonds c'est tellement fort déficit quand
même des guérites voit rien n'allait une
enquête commanderie tout le monde à
toutes formes stefan kuhn trash mais 4
mdt complètement ajoute on ne la votent
oui quelle belle comme parce que la
deuxième on s'est revu le lendemain puis
quinconces et vu mais je connais pas
fait que ces s'appuie comme d'habitude
je me suis ouvert quand est-ce qu'ils
insultent était une personnalité d'un
instagram ou le tunnel sous la selle
crois pas mais m'a dit jeunesse comme
gelé comme ploguer genre mais je leur ai
compris que j'avais du monde qui me
suivait non je savais par titouan orange
ans à ce truc s'en sort parce que comme
le à guidel algues qui tient tellement
qu'est ce que tu fais dans fille comme
anti gang ta vie
la réponse c'est sûr je me souviens
postes étaient jetés sous fait que
genre le deuxième jour où j'ai appris
après trois semaines maintenant non il
le suit la première journée ah oui la
première il était allé boire un café lui
en lui et en général esquissait un
christ il m'en a parlé
au début c'était comme un petit titre
s'était pas quelque chose qui y avait
moins de mai la bonne et il rentre mais
avec moi c'est pas quelque chose qui le
préoccupe été mais c'est un petit mais
je pose la question parce que tu y
mettons ici doit rencontrer quelqu'un de
notre âge tout se sait les bonnes
chances qu'ils savent déjà tai chi ou ce
qu'ils savent assez rapidement tes mais
en voyage tout et très complètement qui
ont une vie oui c'est bien ça me tentait
pas je disais que je t'ai étudiants away
d'expliquer tout comment ça marche comme
étant un code dit qu'il fait une vidéo
ton voyage qui quitte en parle plutôt de
sévir encore étudiant après et c'est en
quoi au fait de témoigner
pourquoi tu me prends pas la question
c'est quoi la nôtre l'interrogatoire la
police
mais stéphane fact c'est le fun un
voyage aussi le montant comme
tant qu ils vont suivre comprends pas ce
que tu te dis paris mais c'est une
petite affaire cola avoir oui c'est cela
pas de suite mais un peu fier bah oui
mais il ya de quoi être fier pauvreté
construire quelque chose de ce patron de
groupe mais bonjour je t'ai vu faire une
coupe des coupes de contrebande de tabac
j'en ai fait deux quand tu es rendu mais
ton petit quand tu es rendu en thaïlande
un contrat comme ça ça peut te faire
durer longtemps la thaïlande
tiens tellement ça coûte pas cher là-bas
le fait tout acteur voyager est-ce que
tu avais de l'argent accumulé avant ce
ou non une question doivent aborder gens
racontent comment faire pour vivre c'est
quoi ces sept mois un voyage paris en
argent sale est sûr c'est que non c'est
tout mon argent mais en gros depuis deux
ans je m'ai 50% mais pas de côté chris
weston parce que je ne dépense pas
beaucoup nous envient sort dans boissons
non la boisson que la bouffe pas mal
mais seules dépenses
c'est un peu à peu j'ai vu un minibus
était quand même c'était avant que tu
parles piste est comme le menu de l'inpi
jean-michel c'était juste comme l'était
les litchis part on le sait les vrais
encore well et à quel genre tu accuses
puis vint le départ
voilà c'était mon appart d'état qui est
encore là où j'étais encore lorsque le
calice mais j'ai mixinge et modifie mes
affaires de quad large médias place de
rien faire chez nous je fais rien mais
je forçais me aude gym danse pas je suis
conscient pour 106 et 110 ha place de me
commander de la marguerite mais je m'en
veux m'acheter des pâquis 2
football à l'épicerie et adroit bien
sorti et oui je les égorgeais fait des
incantations magiques mais bon tu m'as
tu as 50 % du fait que je mettais 50%
mais de courte et fait que j'avais un
bon montant sur le côté mais ça fait au
canada est venu pour ses collègues est
en train de travailler avec la police
pour pour que ce qu'à l'horizon jamais
été au courant pays maudit corps de
conseils de farce
il faut lui même conseillé de sucer les
policiers pas vraie vie je sais que je
suis en train de travailler sur d'autres
contrats que probablement que je veux
même pas garder cet argent me pique mes
t-shirts le gie jamais une dette dans ma
vie aussi j'ai vraiment été chanceuse
jamais fait que je sais que je vais être
correct je travaille un comptable on l'a
vraiment tant pis tout mais c'était
l'argent de mes impôts
mon voyage que tu devais lecteur pourra
jamais payer puis je ne sais pas je dois
combien hockey khl à ce moment j'ai
encore en mars deux côtés mais je sais
pas
je dois tu le double ça va arriver
éventuellement nous avons un chiffre
soit férié à sousse wafa je pense que je
m'attends à temps tout le temps au près
c'est pire que ce à quoi tu t'attends de
lost in by le pont ne prend même pas le
venezuela le choix lisent en ado est pas
là deux par l'argent du zinc était
travail des travailleurs autonomes qui
fait déjà et qui les financent angers
dans ce [ __ ] de plus que la vie nous
rattrape pareil mais en même temps en
même temps 10 ans je trouve que ça en
dit long sur l'unicité de ta personne
parce que n'importe qui n'importe quelle
compagnie mettons qu'il fait juste
d'écrire ce que tu viens de décrire le
le fait que tu dans ta vie tu remets
ferme les yeux sur certaines de la foire
tutu dernière minute et par tortue du
cancer les trucs dernière minute
n'importe quelle compagnie frais mais
ton juste avoir sur papier frais non on
prend pas cette personne mais je trouve
que ça en dit long sur la personne qui
est et sur l'espèce de personnages
uniques que tu es dans la sphère de tout
sauf québec que crise les compagnies
veulent toi
malgré tout ce dont on en a été ta le
fait que le fait que tu viens ici puis
on dit est ce que tu veux pas parler tu
dis non puis chris tu pleures au podcast
le genre moi je trouve que ça dit
vraiment quelque chose par rapport à a
commenté puis la raison pour laquelle
les cons
banny puis le monde en général tu suives
pitié des fans moelleux d'un matin même
si mes tontons mais tant que double de
mes abonnés sur instagram genre plus que
seul le temps que demain matin j'irai
gagne à les suivre
dom c'est mon meilleur ami yves jamait
se rendent à 36 30 mille abonnés de se
désabonner japonaise de poney 2 mois
mais s'étaient abonnés sont tellement
fidèle le monde qui t'écoutent des
tellement louis lequel remonteront crise
malgré tout ce que je sais que toi tu
sais tabarnak ça ça me dérange pas ça
m'arrange pas puis ça je trouve ça
s'appelle long sur tout sur toile et
c'est sûr que c'est surtout quelle
chanson guillemets ou quel que tu as
trouvé un créneau dans lequel tu
excelles c'est dans ce que tu fais dans
est une période non mais j'ai tellement
de gens qui te suivent tu es tellement
gens qui suivent qui t'aime qui tue pas
malgré des imperfections malgré tes tout
ce que tu fais malgré tes opté beau mais
non mais non mais les pertes agricoles
ou de films la phase aller non mais
quelle malgré six parce qu'il ya
tellement dit pas que j'imagine que tu
aurais pu être la pire employés ou et
hama a pour fonctionner le tout en un et
là dessus j'ai déjà new delhi jobs le
mot et travailler en charcuterie travail
dans un mcdonald's rhenatic développe de
ski travail de la charcuterie en lice
j'étais tellement mauvaise dans tout le
monde mais il sèche
je travaille avec moi c'était l'enfer
parce que un support des lic
j'ai pas de mémoire je suis pas capable
mais pich gaffeur qui l'en faire une
chambre
c'est ce que je suis au top je
m'attacherai à l'école ça les cames en
tête stoppée ou
une chanceuse que j'avais pas besoin d
d'étudier fort d'avoir des nôtres tiges
des pages avaient pas d aller comme une
brillante naturelles dont certains armés
titre teams et on le classique faire une
certaine en français parce que tu vas
faire c'est utiliser trop trop de bons
mots pour comme à voir le nombre de
monde
voiçi comme je trouvais le tour de force
dans toutes les matières
c'était comme faire en sorte qu'elles
croient que je suis bien mais que dans
le fond on fait pareil mon père qui fait
ça mais si elle me disait à chaque fois
que tu écris un chiffre qui est plus
longue que quatre chiffres
un homme qui plombe quatre chiffres
écrit la lettre genre toutes les dates
écrit les d'apprendre l'allemand comme
ça que j'aime on retient est bonne on
écrivait bon nombre de la gamme mégane
règles officielles à partir de tels
chiffres écrit un mail mais se pose des
questions on applique ce universellement
c'est comme hockey et ça marche pas à ta
job si tout le monde se pose c'est à
chier interface city ou à l'école ça
marche pas il ya quelque chose dans
lequel qui était bondé cavada feutre ou
cette chose de tout le trouver j'ai tapé
quelques jeunes c'est aussi vous êtes si
on finit 4 par 4 en 10 ans soyez
meilleur que vous étiez soit la
meilleure version de vous même
oui absolument
si je m'en allais oui et 1 ne pas avoir
de plan b c'est full important pour
réussir lorsque tu veux réussir parce
que c'est un plan b la tonne toute mon
énergie ce fois que ce pas sur quelque
chose parce que tu es comme oh je veux
continuer de mettre des oeufs dans le
panier le niveau des métaphores s'excite
juste un plan assez ton seul choix tu te
poses pas d'échappatoire si tu réussis
pas au fait que paul choix de se voir
faire fonctionner faute bête employés de
votre une manière exacte et j
pendant un an et une année dans ma vie
je vivais je vivais avec trois gars ben
miro tourisme en pis j'avais j'ai fait
8000 $ cette année là en tout en douze
mois j'ai fait 8000 dollars sur le seul
trophée et puis j'ai faut le prix du
poids cette année là parce que je
mangeais juste part des pinottes
littéralement ch pour l'âge moyen des
cuillères et de mort des pinottes puis
ma chambre c'est quand tu seras entrer
dans la partie
il y avait un rideau sur le côté dans
l'entrée qui trouve le rideau puisque
c'est un matelas à terre avec mon linge
à terre page avait pas de meubles qui
pose de rideaux dans snow kit est pour
nous un moment donné ce nom
il ya eu juste remarquer que je n'ai pas
sorti de ma chambre la journée parce que
tu es je pouvais pas sortir je prends
mes frères j'avais pas d'argent fait
main juste glissé un football qui avait
fait en dessous de mon rideau pour être
fin parce qu'il avait remarqué que
j'avais pas manger tristesse étaient
jetés le mais il n'était pas question
que je fasse autre chose c'était ce que
je voulais faire et je pense la première
fois jeudi sur internet meetic justice
je pense si tu mets tout dans l'énergie
tu vas l'avoir en amazonie 7e pas le
choix parce que toute autre chose qu'il
n'aura pas le choix de trouver des
moyens
ouais fait que ça qui est deux on le
sait au fond qui est le genre d'affaires
qui nous anime des pièces qui nous rend
heureux pour vrai et juste de suivre ça
tout le temps ça finit par ims a fini
par pays
c'est un plus c'est un peu beaucoup sur
le fichage je pense qu'une grande partie
de ce qui a fait que j'ai pu me rendre
où j'ai envie de vous j'ai eu envie
d'être c'est que beaucoup de ces
officines et cela il ya énormément d
tu peux pas prendre en considération le
tank sur le monde qui dépend de toi ou
tu peux pas avoir du monde qui dépend de
toi ce sera la chine souvent par
décevoir mais je pense quand même que
celle utilisée gens qui sont vraiment
altruiste les sont toujours là pour les
autres
souvent je pense que ça vient que ti
faut que ce soit bien que toi même où
avant d'être capable est bon avec les
autres le fait qu'il confiera on est dix
mains toute confidence je pense que
c'est important de prendre soin soit
d'abord ensuite quand ça s'est réglé
tout voir le temps pitois l'énergie pour
les réseaux pour prendre soin des autres
foule qui a faim la journée c'est aider
les autres c'est aussi parce que ça nous
fait sentir bien nous oui
tout vient des on est tout notre petit
nombril du monde
on est tout seul fait que je sais pas
c'est comme c'est important c'était
tellement important
si tout le monde se fiche ça va
tellement facile c'est mika ding je
trouve
parce que justement pris son bonheur
personnel
de plus il n'y a pas besoin d'avoir les
autres pour les des tirs ou je sais pas
si tout le monde sait priorise mais on
est tout le monde heureux des fois que
la définition de ce prix varie d'une
personne à l'autre
c'est aussi ces genres font des
milliards sur le dos d'enfants qui
travaillent il ya des variantes mais
c'est mieux pour moi
trois mois seulement il ya 30 ans mais
voilà moi ça me rend heureux
histoire est un heureux
si on allait encore oui je pars à bombay
12h10 dessus après trente et un missile
[Rires]
mais probablement j'ai vu quelque chose
de vraiment parlant il faut rebondir ce
qu'on disait juste avant dernièrement
sur instagram puis brian le copain de
diabète est vraiment le jeu trouve jean
tu vas attend juste la preuve on y
compte à 15 mais ton je suis sur leur
dit dans la salle à manger historische
cours d'eau jusqu'à quelque chose
vraiment je n'aimerais vraiment ceci
étant dit ce que j'ai observé la semaine
passée qui met dans l'historie géante
conçue pas attendre la gang
puis j'ai regardé m l'historie à mon
fils le vol historique bryan qui parle
du truc pour les abriter
là il en parle pendant comme 8 story
deux camps mais il trouve ces deux là
vont en fait moi je me dis crise ça
hôtel est bon alors il était déjà au
groupe adam et jeudi au teil il
cautionne s'appuie un cas qui dit je
vois jamais faire la promo de trucs que
je crois pas je la crois que ça fait que
je fais comme ça ça doit fonctionner sa
tête
la story jarre 2 story plus tard c'est
toi que c'est très clair on les a
d'autres faits il me l'envoyer voulait
sûrement que j'en parle en bien merci
que cela m'a jamais ça dans ma boîte de
trucs qui ne servira jamais plus
est acceptée a compté le t2t défaut
c'était quoi tu utilisais l'ailé pour
les yeux les faux vers le contact que tu
avais ou que tu avais envoyé sur la
bourde de trucs qui travaille au service
jeunesse ont encore des trucs que
j'utiliserai pas l'affairé
la compagnie dispose est payé au québec
il m'a envoyé salage ans pis le jeter
comme un roc et ouais je veux l'essayer
joe volpe si ça marche bien bon on va on
va y aller avec le contre que qui est
exposé fait qu'un beau gros montants
d'argent aux mondiaux en salle et pierre
avec le goethe arrivé à l'âge ans puis
en nageant india et 10 ans ils ont
envoyé sur cette arrivée dans sa queue
leu leu il montre puis ça s'appelle un
certain nom puis sur le sur le pakistan
n'ont fait que c'est comme un affaire en
ligne comment ça s'appelle shopping
shopping tactile lui ici commune
en tout cas je sais pas même si ceux ci
le concept à base de ce que j'en
comprends c'est que ces mettons des
militants qui sont experts en marketing
web qui vont qui vont pas dans un
produit mettons 40 pias un t-shirt plus
folle brendle c'était boxeur 1 cuil mais
en réalité lui achètent ce qu'ils
achètent à 3 pias enchères qu'il va 40
kg astuces à fait juste l'intermédiaire
de plus mais qui met ça dans un beau
paquet
très méritant crème commencer la part
fait qu'ils l'ont pas encore fait mais
je comprends le pilote ktm est sûr c'est
qu'il fait dans l'oubli son logiciel
flash soit à montréal qui des maillots
de bain a lâché ses maillots sur alibaba
puis à dire manaway ça a été des cours
et je pense à départ c'est un mettons un
influenceur qui va faire ça parce qu'il
ya une grosse tribune puis qui va
utiliser ça pour vendre quelque chose
qui sait très bien que c'est pas si
poliacik j'avoue mettez y mettons que ta
job toi c'était vraiment bon pour faire
du marketing parce que soient ses
produits le lion ils n'ont pas demain
qu'ils sont pas bons la date enfants
c'est comme si le produit de la qualité
c'est une équipe marketing mais c'est
l'équipe marketing qui prend les
messines on sait juste que c'est normal
quand tu payes quelque chose mais temps
incertain est pris à un bon prix pense
que c'est de la qualité où tu t'attends
ce que ça c'est un niveau puis en fait
c'est de la scrap fait enchaîner mais
c'est juste fou que ça sera pareil au
pire studio comment la qualité avant de
l'acheminer dans une seule la guerre
mais c'est que si ça se produit le gg
même pas j'ai même pas vu l'emballage ou
à l'inversé juste me disent tu as remake
un autre nom que ce que c'était supposé
être fait que je pense que tu devrais
pas mon combat
oui c'est un bon chèque par exemple ça
allait d'un collègue pour toi ces bandes
je sais maintenant c'est ça s'est
vraiment fait que je suis je suis
venez chez nous je l'essayé pareil mais
aussi j'avoue j'ai chanté aussi qui
m'influence beaucoup là-dedans parce que
j'en lis pense que c'est de l'accord les
amarres c'est qu'il faut que tu
travailles tu es abouti je comprends
c'est vrai que ça les très petits jeux
maintenant une foule puis je les gardais
me après avoir fait ma story germi me
succède à mollir me mets pas la même
journée dans une semaine après je lire
essayé mais si tu prends ça en pensant
que tu vas voir des abdominaux fin de
ton moi parce que je fais 20 minutes par
jour car je pool pro puis on devrait
probablement coûté brian parce que c'est
lui
non mais écoutons toujours le vieux kiwi
mais non mais non c'est à cause que 4%
de bois du fer depuis que l'effet qu'a
pu s'entraîner tous les jours tu
essayais pas s'écrire dans vie mais n'y
a pas d'homme était pas
c'est brian l'essec l'hystérie brian sur
les gueux je marque marc pittie sec en
crise le royaume oublié la pièce à
bruxelles et moi toi
brian marque
[Rires]
salut marseillais
non mais ça m'impressionne ça prend
vraiment mais mais mais mais mme chan
johnny c'est qu'aussi vraiment climat
change we still life ces images et de la
marde plus qu'ils mangent la junk images
comme un des gars la cei donne le goût
de cendre et n'est plus non il publier
plus gros parce qu'un train depuis
qu'ils mangent la main parce qu'il ya
tellement grain peas est assailli en
train beaucoup pour ce cas le risque qui
sont restés pour rester tout un voyage
ces déjeuners où mcdonald's et taco bell
sa santé mais c'est pas tout le temps
c'est pas de chance je pense rien fait
cet endroit des canaris menacé cette
baisse pour ce qui est pour ceux qui a
le droit de manger autant que ça c'est
vraiment au pire au début de mon voyage
comme j'étais au début comme que je
voyageais avec lui et j'ai pris feu le
poids parce que je mangeais dit mettront
plus aller manger jeté comme un crime
aussi fiables avant que je commence à
m'entraîner et c'était pas bon pour moi
non magique en main et cape 200 livres
spécialité tout le stock a crû de 5,9
non j'ai pas une bonne idée et j'ai une
remarque écrase de dire dort en ce
moment au chili et puis je voulais
laisser en vie avant de commencer car
nicole harel et demandant vous le voyez
pas malice et nicole
on adore ah ouais la game avant que ce
que de la technique
mickaël alphonse et m'a dit que c'était
nickel 4,6 parler de faits prendre le
maquis puis ouvrir la suite les gens ont
entendu ta merveilleux d'intervention
des impôts qui le numéro 5
nico a aimé le wild et à son nikon non
mes jours pour que les autres aillent
jusqu'en 2001
non mais et le micro hybride pour
l'instant mais l'avenir dire salut dans
le roi juste que les gens voient et te
vois une école ce qu'elle a dans notre
pays bon ben vous présente nicole c'est
notre but disaient d'aujourd'hui à la
concerne
on espère qu'il va être le plus souvent
un truc de son d'acquérir cette belle
journée
ouais c'est vrai que c'est nicole
[Rires]
arrêtent ils bombardent arnaque
approchez approchez du mac les deux
c'était quand même temps avec ta et
bryan boussis 5 m
ça fait environ quatre mois qu'on s'est
fait ouais c'est à peu près 10 1 mois
par année
un mois par année reste un mois qu'on
travaille ensemble en plus c'est
possible c'est possible je respecte
beaucoup quand même
puis je trouve que ça serait dommage en
fait de jusqu'à 4 tandis que c'est une
biche des enfin c'est ce que j'ai fait
bastien pour savoir ce qu'on met encore
une que peu qu'on est pressé
c'est le témoignage si on commence on
est l'un des frères fait trois ans et
moi j'avais avec août je voulais à
tanger une question avec en charge le
sujet je m'excuse je te coupe la marque
a besoin
il s'est dit qu'est ce que je suis la
finale à la casse mais moi ça traîne ce
coupé la nasa ce qu'est ce que j'ai
appris après ski motiondsp exo parce que
c'est qu'on a reçues les gags gabon fine
après notre sur les grilles à vos films
sur le podcast
je te rappelle que moi j'étais parti
parce qu'on était trop chaud on était
partis puis c'était resté au bord en
charge et apple c'est tout cas n'est le
sujet n'ont pas si j'ai changé c'est le
passé tout le monde est lancé non mais
attends le savais pas que ça s'en aller
dès dans ma vie amoureuse avec on savait
qu'on a reçues des gags à mon fils et
j'ai pas vu
méthode de touche quand les avait reçus
et je pense pas que tactique j'ai peur
on a pris une bien après c'est parler de
soi ce qui me rappelle que j'avais vu
qu'il critique pour les internautes
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont lésés par il s'est
tu pour un non
c'est le tchèque réellement bonfillon
faire du genre ils sont étranglés honte
une belle chance en culotte et gagnent
ces crimes biche et on a mangé de la
viande au big mac
bon ok les gars vous ne savez jamais ce
que j'allais dire c'est que si tu as la
fin du podcast pas à la fin le soir mais
la saison passée
t'as fait une petite montée de l'état à
son insu oui ce fut la réponse attendent
avec dvd de vence puis on a reçu avec un
podcast catherine brunet au podcast les
succès oui mais j'ai juste écouter le
bout parce qu'on a parlé de ce sujet la
cloche pendant pas mal dans une mine ah
ouais ouais c'était vraiment autour de
ce petit bout catherine brunet à ce que
je sais moi c'est un ehpad caste que
j'ai préféré faire mais je trouve pas
rallumer sépare intéressant jamais on
sait déjà croisé des événements
on sait jamais par les petits je
trouvais qu'elle avait acheté des points
ou des critiques qu'elle a menée
vis-à-vis des influenceurs des réseaux
sociaux du ce était pour la majeure
partie valide fait que j'ai plutôt que
d'écouter
si tu étais en de l'accord désaccord ben
je sais pas mais je sais pas trop je
pense que je pense que ce que disait
principalement par rapport à je me
souviens c'est la proximité des deux
s'ouvrir qu'à pense qu'a trouver wild
c'était le réflexe de si loin à de
parler du réflexe de peyo qui décrit une
situation dans le taxi soir lorsque des
clichés d'un taxi milanais n'a ni sa
tombe est comme ça tombait comme bien
que ce soit à ce moment là parce que ça
faisait deux jours que dit la sphère de
paix au burundi un taxi était sorti puis
puis elle avait même pas parler de ce
mets par la critique qui faisait des
influenceurs par son personnage
on attendait ça son grain de sel est
arrivé depuis api puis elles se sont
point c'était de dire
drôle de réflexes que ce soit la
première chose qui me viennent en tête
que de prendre ton sa place de dire ok
maintenant il faut que j'appelle un ami
faut que je paye une condition au que je
trouve une solution tout film pour
montrer qu est ce qui se passe
ouais t'es puis moi de nous en
débattrons gt gt gt complètement
d'accord avec elle je trouve ça étrange
comme comme réflexe c'est vrai c'est
vrai c'est pas j'ai un fils et vous
alors que ton premier réflexe de vouloir
filmer documenter une situation de ta
vie en assumant que ça va intéresser les
autres jeux l'accord j'avoue que ce qui
est aspect là aussi c'est que c'est
vraiment d'assumer que ça va intéresser
les gens qui se les est pertinent
willows inn sort je comprends mais en
même temps il n'y a rien de une croûte
de angelina jolie si michael être
complètement libre jusqu'à ce que tu ne
brime pas la liberté les autres que
il fait tout ce que tu veux tant que tu
ne fais rien pour intentionnellement
faire du mal aux autres
ça c'est ma devise tu fais ce que tu dit
najlae lhimer
la première fois ma vie enfin pas mini
pas rater il ya mettons y avait un ami à
allier en est qui qui s'adapte à malmö
tentij pas gagner la gauche obama
s'était auparavant ces thèmes a rejeté
l'offre quoi pourquoi ça m'a dit fais ce
que tu veux
dans la vie tu fais ce que tu veux tant
que ça fait mal à personne ne fait de
mal à personne parce que tu veux
maintenant sienne allemand pu laisser
des gens sans vouloir puisse en avoir
des mauvaises intentions ou st t ça
arrive
non c'est ça ouais métier attention
parité mais très positif attendu et il
ya plein d'affaires qui est caché par
les normes ou à la vérité qui fait
qu'ils ont fait mais si un réflexe
étrange c'est différent maintenant
baisse
elle avait aussi besoin c'est différent
parce qu'il ya quelqu'un d'autre le
chauffeur de taxi que rien demandé
qu'est ce qu'on fait monsieur bay 6
coffrets ben oui je pense que des femmes
il m'a dit dans le fond lui y aller
quelque part le matin tu as pris un taxi
puis à payer avec sa carte la marcha car
ces gens lèvent pas le fait qu'il y au
film une chaufferette nounoune attention
tandis que moi je les vis à main milieu
justement ce serait la moins pire et où
il ya pas mal impressionné de me voir
parce que j'étais quand même vocale par
rapport au fait qu ils déconnent que
pour moi pour moi c'est sans doute ça
donne ça déjà taxi clairement difficile
puis continent sans faire parler
constance faire intimider plus que
jamais je vais accepter ce monsieur
l'intimé de poche juste pas d'accord
avec ça puis je trouve ça exprime un
point plus grands qui est de justement
tu fais pas de mal
tant que tu fais pas de mal à personne
je peux faire ce que tu t'es toi tu avec
patates peu de films phares ce que tu
veux c'est notre but finger pas tarder à
moins de pâte à peine pas simple mais
laisse aussi par exemple au rsa c'est
oui non mais là ça fait du mal à patates
ouais c'est ça ce n'est pas le fun pour
patate mettant métier mettons que tout
seul chez vous personne parce qu'avec
sim et on est revenus et vous piquer tu
dis ce que tu veux qui fait pas mal à
personne c'est correct
par contre je vais jamais accepté peu
importe c'est quoi la situation je sais
que c'est chiant je sais que les taxis
ces rentrées arqués comme façon de
transporter stocker baer qui payent déjà
automatiquement tout ça c'est déjà réglé
sur les taxis sont arriérés
la plupart du temps ils prennent pas de
carte parce qu'ils veulent ils veulent
payer ils veulent pas payer le frais vie
n'aurait pas payé les frais de taxi je
suis d'accord ex hubbard tellement forme
je descends arabo exactement la mini kit
heureux que ce soit les taxis ces
requêtes
c'est la mère de la pop star mais je
n'avais jamais accepter que quelqu'un
film une autre personne sans son accord
pour y donner de la marde ce ça va
jamais pensé ce qu'on prend d'accord
avec toi dans le sens c'est vrai péault
c'est une bonne personne
persuadé je pense que comme a dit
catherine c'est un réflexe du genre
c'est vraiment spécial comme réflexe qui
je lis aussi puis après le monde qu'ils
ont fait c'est comme ça et ça toi je
t'ai jamais vu faire
je t'ai jamais vu à l'effet quelqu'un
d'autre a qu'en négatif je t'ai jamais
vu mettons du monde une petite fille qui
danse dès demain qt pis mais tu veux je
n'ai jamais vu montrer quelqu'un à
négative inclure quelqu un dans ton dans
tes stories un club figurant des poses
qui a rien demandé je t'ai jamais vu
faire ça ce que je comprends encore une
fois se passe qui paie aussi mon ami
puis j'ai beaucoup de respect pour lui
je pense qu est ce qu une erreur mais
tous imparfaits fait tous des erreurs
puis le fait d'être influenceurs ça les
expose quand tu fais une exemple riz moi
je peux faire une niaiserie personnes
veulent savoir c'est tout ce que tu as
réussi métis non feinte 10 000 cartes
ont permis aux personnes en parlent
comme s'ils apportent wasicka maïs asus
c'est je perds mon permis je dis c'est
pas de caste c'est moi le permet sinon
personnel sinon personne seule m haies
mais c'est arrivé à québec c'est bon
métier fait c'est sûr de capter
d'influenceurs une marche de côté puis
tout le monde est au courant du mois
passé la partie prenante de ta vie je me
fais juste rappeler des fois que j'ai
dit des trucs de travailleurs passent
des fois c'est une question de m'en
excuse moi des fois c'est une question
de monde commence à interpréter
l'eau c'est sûr que c'est un autre
niveau le sait filmer quelqu'un c'est
sûr mais c'est juste pays son taxi ben
c'est ce qui aurait dû faire mais je ne
sais pas il faut les pauvres
chaque art le botswana ou sexuellement
ont commencé à dos d'une carte cadeau
c'est lui qui me mauvais temps une carte
cadeau nos métiers y en a d'autres
options qui débarque mois plus loin chez
un ami on va régler ce débarquement un
guichet à voter oui je sais pas d'autre
option
les matchs en ce moment fait pas de la
simulation vraiment du monde qui avait
aucune des sept équipes qui le
connaissent que pour celui ci sait aussi
c'est que ça se place sur tout le monde
d influence non mais oui s'il en est ça
sonnait labarde l'estimant non huawei et
bouby oui oui on devrait écouter je
considère pas ce que c'est je pense que
écouter le monde quand on n'est pas
d'accord ça ne fait pas qu'en france
c'est sur c'est quoi on va naïveté
c'était vous devriez c'est vrai que
c'est vrai qu'on s'est parlé on a été
vraiment et on en savait trop
la chute aux excités à l'idée qu'il dit
si changer de nom fait des gros gros
gros tu en as besoin de déjà vu pensez
vous que tout don fait par la pj
regarder avec claudia un épisode qui
sont sentis un peu de toi non jeûne est
ce que ça fonctionne qui essayait une
couple de fois dans ma vie
puis à chaque fois parce que je trouve
que mon je l'entends pas mon coeur qui
bat on attend pas mais que je fume et je
joue je l'entends dire présentant
parfois quand mon coeur bat pauline
fidji comme oh my god je veux mourir
dans ma tête je vais mourir à chaque
fois ci mon anxiété de foule de social
d'amitié déjà je me met à imaginer que
tout le monde parle dans mon dos
qu'iliad les conspirations que tout le
monde déteste fait encore je peux pas je
peux pas fumer un passé j'étais déjà
mangé ou non une fois j'avoue j'ai dit m
des mini jeux les fêtes pendant son bac
s avec fou qui j'éprouve un jeu michael
au début ce podcast puis à 40 minutes
dans le podcast là je me suis plus à
manger quand j'écoutais ce podcast là
j'ai regardé c'était moi qui s'occupait
des caméras changer les caméras je
regardais fille selon des fois j'en
refais ou qui parlent parlent comme un
bond de seconde pige
je sais dans quel monde tu fais de ce
oui et puis le fait qu'au final je la
laissais seul white plus bas 4
pas besoin de faire des deathwish de
gamme la mechta les foules c'est bien
pour ça allez sur un pont de 15 avec
adamo que je connais à peine c'est
peut-être à pied non pas que je fasse
avec des amis de ma part mais tout à la
fois que je défende en mangeant jugé
avec mon meilleur ami jerry j'ai déjà eu
du plaisir
l'alcool le monde et sont assez
intelligents mais sans qu'on n'avait pas
fait le tour du sujet tantôt aux 6 4 ou
6 à 7 avait nommé d'ici là parce que je
les sentais mon espèce few de vieux non
dit la cépière le qui faisait toi je
pense que je peux de la manade lafon la
gagne la gang du chalet c'est ce que des
acteurs de brad pitt pierrelatte phone
control avec d'autres personnes moi même
je sais qu'ils les autres acteurs jean
blanc mais l'a fait parce que l'effet
est une photo c'est toi tu es pour max
bourguet coiffant ses clients d
principal photo de groupe pour ses
cheveux pour s'en rendre compte en effet
à être pris une photo pl
un jour il y avait fait en réponse une
photo comme cela fait trois cadres ont
la tête haute école de catch était and
friends c'est la fête c'est les
intentions derrière c'est si ça avait
été fait par une gamme de go que qu'on
connaît mais ayant connaissait dans le
gros bon sens crousillat aussi est havre
ac qui était dans la photo t - garde
c'est drôle c'est faux
mais si les intentions et beaucoup de
tiges me suis comme a emporté la
dernière fois puis c'est dommage je
préfère qu'un qu'ils restent calmes tout
se joue je pense que c'est être blessé
c'est plus de sentir beaucoup de
jugement de vous ne connaissez pas je
fais quelque chose de différent mais qui
est pour moi une valeur s'est senti que
s'ils me sentir dévalorisés dans ce que
je fais comme si c'était pas aux valides
ça me fait de la peine pour ce que je
peux m'en porte et fait que c'est sur
quelqu'un que je me sens visé puis pidcp
avec mon problème c'est peut-être mon
problème même sens terroriser mais fait
que mais c'est aussi facilement je peux
prendre les choses personnelles puis je
peux et je suis consciente de ce que je
remarque beaucoup plus facilement les
critiques négatives que positives unis
j'ai une grande envie de plaire si pour
secret je le ressens pied c'est dommage
mais fait que c'est sur quelqu'un qui a
des enfants de même ça me dise a pu
venir me touche et très sec pour ce qui
est de de critiquer les influenceurs je
comprends je comprends tout ça vient
mais à la fin de la journée il n'ya pas
de mal qui fait si tu le fais dans les
corps et à cris que tu prends le monde
des choses en quoi je crois c'est est
honnête si je veux pas défendre tout le
monde c'est comme tout les acteurs il y
en a de différent il ya différents de
toutes les influences heures c'est juste
on est souvent mis dans le même bateau
tu es ici comme dans le podcast
happily il parle du fait que et au bourg
dont il savait comment était la tête de
turc je pense est en fête et au besoin
et c'est ce qui est arrivé il faut que
toutes les influences chez moi j'ai vu
des postes des gens relativement
crédible d une influence à cause de sa
femme
des gens d'aider des gens du milieu du
showbiz je trouve ça je trouve pas ça
correct puis je pense que l'eau tu vois
j'aurais tendance à dire c'est mon cas
raison chose que je veux que les mots
influenceurs et vraiment on a galvaudé
je trouve que l'utilité mais je suis là
je décollais définition exacte je trouve
que les andes est une personnalité du
web dati la faire c'est que c'est pas ce
que je fais pas c'est pas mon travail
j'avais bien lemay thivierge
il vendait ses collègues
est ce que c'est un influenceur parce
qu'ils influencent les gens achetaient
des noms du quad c'est quoi la
différence que dans le fond tu des
personnalités publiques d'assistanat qui
faisaient des peuples et fait des pubs
pour maxi en faisait pour en deux c'est
quoi la différence entre mon arrêt
accents n'occupe qui sait pas faire ça
at il fait des pubs à l'eau voici ma
nouvelle crème que j'adore tout le monde
me demande qu'est ce que je mets dans
mon visa tout le monde
vous êtes de plus en plus de mettre
mardi nana na na na na ce que j'ai
commencé à faire c'est quand je reçois
des messages
je me fais souvent demandé je connais
screenshot des questions jpost hockey et
moi par rapport à toute cette histoire
le trop chaud à l'ouest et surtout sa
première marche aussi mais ton site sans
dévaloriser quoi que ce soit aussi
certaines personnes pensent qu est ce
que tu ailles pendant les deux mois
personnellement je suis pas d'accord je
trouve que tu as un talent qui jetait
j'irais jusqu'à dire exceptionnelle qui
est différent de doter nos robes énorme
et ttt des dépôts une comédienne n'était
peut-être pas osé y mettez quelqu'un qui
construit quelque chose puis qu'un
talent dans le fixe et des gens qui
s'intéressent à toi parce que tu fais
puis la faire c'est que pourquoi je n'ai
pas de leur faute c'est de ma faute cdc
des pointes qui vont atteindre + team
étant quelqu'un comment quelqu'un c'est
des critiques qui viennent dans même
c'est parce que c'est des gens qui n'ont
pas c'est plus sain à faire de moi même
j'ai des doutes
comme si tu pertinence que je fais et je
sais que ça le spo négatif ce que je
fais c'est positif la majorité du temps
mais je me demande souvent si ce que je
fais et pertinents puisqu'elle fait
qu'un que le monde sont comme sérieux
pourquoi vous la suivez gens c'est pas
intéressant ce qu'a dit alors rien à
dire de c'est sûr que ça martin parce
que je le gip ans mon cij le fait que
c'est sûr que quand je vois se passait
jusqu'à ce très bon point à un point
d'eux qu'ils connaissent et qui a dit il
ya plein de monde qui m'accusent de
débouler un goût de thé l'intimidation
de ce parti nation avait dit moi je fais
juste pour rire c'est pas méchant pis
c'est juste pour ramener un côté ludique
est inférieur à 10 j'ai l'impression
qu'on se prend sparrow sérieuses
internet était sérieux mais juste faire
des jokes pire et puis mes tantes et
catala à l'autre et écrit des affaires à
ph adamo petit adam ou des foyers
répondait une joke pilotes comme ça on
sait comment on rit t il
je sais que tu connais pas la personne
des fois tu sais pas l'intention se
situe parce que vraiment avec piqué ou
c'est parce que c'est juste une blague
mais regardez ce que c'est quelque chose
qui a dit hadi qui est moi qui disait
elle telle personne n'est vraiment pas
content et vraiment influent que tu là
notez qu est l agence je sais même pas
ce que faisait après mais juste
j'éprouve rien les affaires de l'or
métal audel parce que c'est venu
c'est venu sur le fait qu'il était au
podcast moi c'est sûr mais c'est zéro le
cpo qu'un que j'ai dit ce que je pensais
pas à m spécifiquement le bon je pense à
personne en particulier avec un que j'ai
dit tout ce que j'avais personnes en
panne
c'est vraiment un enfer de en général le
show business au québec qui autre que ce
soit des humoristes que ce soient des
acteurs des chanteurs wever qui sont pas
tant et tant qu'ils n'ont pas envie d'un
sur le web qu'on pense d'eux se montre
de se mettre en scène ce moyen un
préjugé puis je le comprends dans le
sens que d'autres confessent et on ouvre
une caméra au genre spirit et outils new
new new new new qu'on fait tout le pij
comprend d'où ça vient c'est juste ça
peut être blessant si tu parle de
quelque chose que tu connais pas ils
nous connaissent autant que ceux ils
vont pas en profondeur arrivons avec les
red wings qui vont voir leur père doit
utiliser car tiendront donc ça allait
plus loin puis comprend ce que c'est
mais 4 à sa défense est allé plus loin
pied était très nuancée pas prendre
cette histoire le précise au moins j'ai
le 3e troisième point que je le dire
c'est justement ce fameux terme
influenceurs le team puis on en parlait
justement le podcast tant qu'à moitié le
fait d'être influenceurs cpo d'époque
connu parce que tu influenceurs d'
influence parce que c'est une
personnalité web qui est devenu connu
qui lot des contrôles ce médecin c'est
quoi la différence entre toi je te bats
ou qui pille on les divers joue comme et
xavier dolan qui et les représentants de
louis mouton je peux quelle compagnie
ouïe fait des films mais il devenu connu
puis moment tu es connu bel olivier
parole pour situer un peu pour sauter la
houle lors de ce qu'on dit claes un
influenceur s'est dernièrement il a
signé un contrat avec un politicien
contre-publicité sur instagram
je pense qu'on va appeler influenceurs
la personne que c'est dur de dire qu'ils
se penchent en temps ce pot un acte ans
pau mais créent du contenu petit fait du
divertissement dans le fond nous tous je
pense que ce qui fait en sorte que en
fait je pense pas si c'est le fait qu'il
ya beaucoup de jugement par un influent
se parlent de toi que tout montre toi
que tu sais tout ces six à chaque
personne influenceurs rien d'autre de
connexion des musiques qui sort c'est
juste je pense qu'il devrait avoir un
autre terme pour les apps nous appeler
je m'inclus parce qu'elle suppose qu'on
ferait pas nécessairement français le
monde ce qu'on veut c'est partager nos
vies je pense qu on a tout différent des
différents motifs différentes
motivations mais si c'est une façon de
vivre de ce que tu fais si je n'étais
pas les publicités le monde par équipes
tchèques ont tenu leur serviette ou
jouera seul c'est comme si si le temps
que tu passes par exemple sur youtube ou
sur à entretenir la communauté sur
instagram
s'il fallait que ce temps leur soit
jamais rémunéré de réponse choix de
faire payer au fait j'oubliais j'ai vu
des la médecine au nom métier où on met
les podcasts sont taxe est accessible à
tout le monde gratuitement sur youtube
sur les applications balado mais ça
coûte pas rien passé je n'ai pas le
choix sinon faudrait que sa bonne
spirale
non merci
sauf que triplé son école gratuitement
d'ici début mai mais non mais c'est son
métier et tout les modèles en train de
changer et l argent comment ça
fonctionne c'est fait les grosses boîtes
qui avait bondi pouvoir bien de l'argent
certaine époque il y en a encore mais
qui voyais les gens migrer vers le web
pour toutes ces personnes est erroné
modèles changent faut trouver de
nouvelles sources de revenus
ces épices et sopi dans vies toutes les
peaux gratis c'est là on est habitué
d'avoir de la musique gratuite des
contenus youtube gratis tout gratis mais
dans la vie ça coûte pour rien à faire
ça qu'il faut faire des pubs des rudes
et c'est ça la réalité peut-être des
fois le monde jean yves un pub c'est pas
4 mais oui mais crise sinon il n'aurait
pas de calais ce mois ben ouais même moi
sûrement browser web
j'ai hâte bloc je vois jamais aucune
équipe est facile peut s'attacher genre
spoiler dans l'aude et atlas parce que
ça nous aide pas fake fait peur mais les
semaines chez foshan hésité pour charlie
sérieux dans notre bloc piles mais le
wes a fait une bouteille i et demi un
peu loin mais celle là dedans s'il a
quitté la qui bougeait choix soit fait
plus que sa pression sur magna
encore marqué en fin de soirée crrr
commune vers la gare d'almeida fera là
[Musique]
on imagine parce que c'était une
campagne c'est même mieux payés mais
temps quelqu'un une seule personne te
juste besoin de payer une seule personne
qui est proche proche proche de son
monde fait que sa voix encore plus
touchés là c'est intéressant
si tu fais un peu bas tv mais tu sais
pas si tu regardes tu étais une fille au
chaud qui est avancé qu'il a été mais
c'est qu'il faut que je paye bien plus
de monde c'est que ça coûte plus cher
aux genevois edmond c'est justement
maintenant regardons l'exemple de biche
dvd c'est le monde qui monte ce pas de
cacher ou est-ce que c'est toi l'invité
c'est directement dans la cible du brain
on s'influence aux influences à ce
moment mais c'était puis mais même peu
comme sa tv ça va te coûter 15 fois le
prix soit rejoindre des baby boomers qui
est que deux amants nord puis pitroipa
appartiendra pas du tout un public cible
non mais non mais je suis sérieux tc
s'appauvrir
c'est ce qui va se passer tu peux rire
tant que tu veux c'est ce bouveret le
public de deuxième en or c'est loin
d'être la clientèle cible de biche début
de loin et en ski si on n'est pas les
plus proches le promoteur lisant burkina
sur les membres tibétains et non un
autre truc puis le ticket je ramène tout
ça il ya catherine kohler sui 6 mai et l
hadopi mais c'est une chose qui moi je
pense qu'on pourrait vraiment bien
s'entendre sur ça pour ça
c'est vraiment juste une histoire dont
on sait jamais rencontré puis on n'a pas
été présentée de faire un nouveau pas de
casques tv 2 personnes à des opposés à
ces ensembles défaite ce soir on reçoit
plus aux besoins des lecteurs n'ont pas
les taxis le garder au chaud les styles
les grêlés sur aucun des clés d'une
grogne générale et on soit plus beau
depuis des années non mais on fait ça on
a des opposés tfs genre qu'on fait ce
que je veux juste m
une des choses qui à 10,6 et i will
influence mais est-ce que l'influencé
toujours positive le csk maison des
associations installées pas le contrôler
c'est dans ce sens l'influencé négative
ou positive c'est pas c'est pas à toi
des on peut pas choisir qui décide de se
mettre ensemble si si des gens des
abonnés ce parce que le monde sont
intéressés on peut pas contrôler 600
positif mais tout ça tout sur certaines
responsabilités par rapport au message
qui est envoyé ou pas vraiment
je sais que je fais attention des
affaires que j'ai dit dans le passé que
je regarde un peu puis je me suis fait
rire crif
mais en même temps j'ai juste des bonnes
intentions puis j'essaie de propager la
positivité fait que je pense pas que
rien à ce que je peux dire même si c'est
super déplacer ça me donne vraiment
vulgaire si j'ai pas l'impression que je
suis pas correct parce que c'est elle je
me suis plus qu'elle organise avec les
quelques collaborent et à 10,6 des
jeunes qui ont des problèmes d'image
d'études et de confiance en soi parce
que ça peut être exacerbée texas avait
pas les réseaux sociaux puis même si la
foule message de boycotter tvm sur
instagram du reste qui règle générale
souvent les comptes qui fonctionne
vraiment où les fixes qui ont fait de
following souvent ces décors assez
esthétique merci soit coupable mardi
john bâtés et elle reste que ces six
essais qui fonctionne mais reste que
c'est ce qui fonctionne le plus c'est ce
qui est des filles regardent plus tard
j'aimerais ci-dessous pilotis fabg un
conseil pour ces gens là perso j'en ai
une qui m'intrigue beaucoup à me chaque
fois que je la suis puis-je land for law
puis des fois je la stocke comme si tu
es quelqu'un que je connaissais que je
voulais pas qu'ils sachent que je la
faune l'eau puis c'est une américaine
d'un million de fort loin de mes jeux la
folle au pot parce que quand je voyais
ces photos dans mon fils ça me faisait
sentir pas bien puis ça triggered
quelque chose en moi de juger plus goût
de manger
jamais de ma vie fait que ces gens là
faut pas les suivre font pire je me
tchéquie son compte yahoo mais je me
retire à l'excès semaine était saine est
une scène dans ce sens sont le corps
qu'ils prennent et inaccessible pour 80
euros qu'ils ont triomphé a pas de co2
quand l'iss mais non c'est sûr pis ça
c'est ici quand je la connais pas je
sais pas ce que c'est absolument pas
mais je collais très ouverte au fait des
projets provinciaux rien là dedans qui -
moi je la vois elle met on put rien là
dedans que je fais ce genre où ses yeux
rien qui n'ait pas de calais du succès
avec les gens regardent se
ressemblent-ils de ce genre du succès
ses pas dans ceux en allemand c'est
c'est vraiment un enfer c'est ça ramène
les gens qui ne font pas sentir bien
quand on les regarde ça ramène dans les
complexes annoncé même pas une affaire
de ski c'est même pas un enfer de ces
j'aime beaucoup l'idée au café je pense
qu'elle super intelligente comme fille
c'est vraiment juste puis la seule
raison pourquoi cela suppose papa je
laime pas au contraire c'est de la
grosse jalousie si je regarde plus comme
j'ai tout le temps eu mettons des
complexes puis le jeu pas les nommer
parce que j'ai eu des complexes je la
regarde et riche comme pourquoi style
même si m'entraîner dur semaine jamais
mon corps au regard de tout ça me fait
sentir pas bien pourquoi je la suivrai
la photo je la trouve esthétiquement
magnifique j'ai le goût de la regarder
pendant des heures mais ça me fait
sentir pas bien fait que jours pour
faire ses basses cartouches la forme de
son corps non absolument pas ah c'était
ça se voit quand je suis pour c'est quoi
son problème et stitch en juste une
alien genre je te jure je l'aï doit
maintenant jusqu'où tu vois la retouche
maintenant sur tes potes on est
lumineuse et je vais aller dans la
luminosité fait que maintenant le que
j'aime pas un ange et démon visait de
mon visage je vais mettre du plus foncé
mettront l'eau pour avoir l'air plus
slim mais je modifie jamais là
l'accord qui va modifier la luminosité
jeu peut tricher dans le métro qui vaut
vraiment là les gros ça laisse un gros
saule est qu à mettre la tête est-ce que
tu un jugement par rapport à ça est ce
que tu es que c'est bien ce que c'est
bien ce que c'est mal ou est-ce que ça
on s'en crée ce que ça fait j'ai encore
sur la ligne de mire
mais en même temps je comprends que
c'est c'est 1,5 hors idéalisé puis de
voir ça ça fait sentir pas bien fait que
je pense pas que c'est cool de faire ça
mais je pense pas que les filles qu'ils
font c'est avec l'intention de spa avec
l'intense si c'est elle même qui ont
comme moi je préférerais comme ça faut
pas penser trop loin de les conséquences
restent les mêmes mais j'essaie juste
encore imaginer être à leur place de
comprendre que mais oui c'est vrai tu es
tu vois ça c'est frustrant d'études à
soi puis tu vois un petit bout de peau
des passivité comme un quartier c'est
pourquoi j'essaie tout le monde sur mes
mains sa g s'est elle fait oublier parce
qu'il est surtout le temps pour states a
pris belles poses ton plus beau profil
qui c'est normal puis mettant quelques
le sait beaucoup de 6 pi beaucoup de
suppositions mais temps quelqu'un qui
dirait qu'il a fait lui le tf olczyk
maman jeunesse gros bug des frites et du
genre c'est important de genre et de
manger ce qu'on veut éviter de 200
permettre mais en réalité la fille à
manches pour le reste de la semaine se
tait dans le fond que les messages que
tu dit dans le fond c'est un peu un
mensonge parce que c'est est-ce que
mentir aux gens ce nom peut s'en sortir
si bien
mais il ya une autre affaire ben ouais
c'était l'avocat du diable mais c'est
fou il ya une histoire qui les fait
souvent avec des troubles alimentaires
ils vont ainsi de se convaincre lui même
fait qu'une fille vraiment mince pies
qui c'est havas convaincre elle même car
elle met sa tête en mange de la marde le
pascaa s'imagine s'imaginent qu'ils trop
inquiète en surpoids qui fait que pour l
anah mange de la marde sans arrêt fait
que cette tête et il pense peut-être
jolie sipa le champ des suppositions
mais six à avoir un trouble alimentaire
c'est croire que tout ce que tu fais
c'est mal que tout ce que tu mets dans
ton corps tu verses mais c'est comme si
tu bouges marque fait que moi je pense
tout comme un check-up pièce in store
des passants terminent tout le temps
mais en même temps c'est sûr c'est un
mensonge puisque dispo correct mais fait
il ya une moralité pareil soit agrandi
mettant les lacs à tout prix à tout prix
amman et ça peut aller trop loin mais
c'est tout le temps l affaire des
comptes explique de qui de quoi piquer
ce jeudi puis c'est quoi le pas aux
piges
j'ai pas envie de dire quelque chose de
général mais chacun fait ce qu'il veut
à noter que tu fais pas de mal je suis
non mais on arrive toujours
toujours dans cette écurie est l'espèce
des points 2 on ne sait pas parce
qu'elle cesse et c'est pas tranché puis
tenue de ces discussions le camp lui un
voyage en lui plusieurs fois puis amman
et si greenpeace savoir rester great
c'est juste pour vrai afin de tout genre
et pas de la fin de la journée je pense
pas à ça se dit de plus en plus parce
que le plus en plus c'est une expression
ça aussi c'est un mix entre marach la
faune non non non non alors ça vaut moi
j'avais une dernière question va gonfler
c'est quoi ton ton highlight de ce mois
le voyage c'est comme étant en attente à
un extrait dans l'image
ça va être maman mais c'est pas ça pête
un moment où ça peut être quelques
heures et samedi c'est le mot complet
obama c'est un gars si le japon est une
photo cette fois j'avais deux ans
j'avais ma ma poche une carte de rené
loyon c'était le même personnage qui
avait le même personnage qui passe et la
frappe
[Rires]
appelez-moi tease pour la baptiser les
jacks abonnez-vous sans fil de vip on en
parle
enfin 30 minutes après le podcast
accusant m
il emmène pas à vous donner mais jamais
une photo mais aussi je commence à être
chaud pour ma moto pratique amateur est
parti j'ai l'impression que j'ai de quoi
vous mettant juste comme quelque chose
qui te tient grandement ce jeu là
quelque chose qui justin vraiment un
point fort ville qui comme acquis et
j'ai tiré mon coup de coeur c'est tokyo
mais this town réponse par place
j'aurais aimé ça te dit quelque chose
que à michael je sais je sais qu'il ya
une journée que j'ai comme c'est le plus
beau jour de ma vie je sais qu'une
journée que c'était ce puits gibbons que
ça devait pâtissier autant trop seule
médaille ou c'était tokyo était un
matériau c'est la prochaine place ce que
je regrette leur c'est je pense que
tokyo pour quelqu'un qui a écouté des
mangas toute sa vie publique et peuple
allait toutefois capoté parce que j'ai
personnellement écouter des mandats
quand j'étais plus jeune mais pour
beaucoup et bien écoutez pas qu'ils
aient pop charrues la piste est quand
même là on écoute moi de mes bons amis
la ville brunel david lui toujours trip
expliqué patrick et sur les mains
stay gold est allé à tokyo avec sa
blonde était son talent
puis
fable honda delà de 500 demandeurs way
ont capoté
ben écoute j'ai même pas eu foule bonne
culture japonaise même pas foule fans la
bourse japonaise
pourtant je pensais poubelle je faisais
je savais que salah et in fine c'est
quand même fou gamecube mais j'arrive il
a bossé jeter le crocheter pas pour
châble je me remets le matin j'avais
levé jeudi si tokyo j'ai capoté
j'avais demandé me ramener un style
c'est un genre manga michael j ai
demandé me ramener ce lieu dit je te
lance une place que plusieurs étages
puis moi je suis allé au deuxième étage
pour des ménages le monde me regardait
comme will un peu caché le seul parce
qu'à part macplus étage monte plus ça
devenait intense lui était au deuxième
sur 5 je pense je m'arrête plus
exactement c'est qu'on vient d'acheter
vous au global mettait au début mais qui
dit moi je me suis arrêté le gepan y ait
un manque donc j'ai trouvé le jeu léché
nous le suggère des robots le qui vive
je me disais ça c'est le deuxième étage
j'ai vu que la gêne au cinquième étage
est arrivé dans un sex-shop de tokyo je
rentre petit juste dire somme de mal au
coeur mais c'est une vidéo
pornographique en 3d d'un enfant mais
c'est pas un vrai enfant sec 3d est
rentré ou c'est normal mais non mr un
sex-shop normal s'il ya des mais c'est
une jeune fille avec des petites bêtes
de petite fille pas de brassières tous
et du 3d - c3d fait que c'est pas une
vraie enfance et c'est ce chemin partagé
la tune en ce sens que non je pense que
non mais attends pourquoi pourquoi kg ça
c'est clair mais ton meilleur aucun
partage non mais au québec tu fais juste
écrire une histoire qui a été qu'il ya
des acquis et que les enfants poussent
et puis c'est pas des greffiers
c'est fait qu'un hologramme investissent
à noter c'est l'enfer il y avait sur la
méthode
michael jackson tout paquet mais y avait
ceux qui jouent moins
savais tu avais une petite vidéo de même
un petit jouet qui montrait le preview
de la vidéo tu fais partie avec lâcheté
c'est horrible à voir c'est vraiment une
école ça mais je suis tout le temps
estimé la force et qu'il paie de films
et selon s'envole loin ça peut pas être
la dernière question je m'embarque là
bas au fond un nombre de voix dit que je
voulais résumé témoins avant même que tu
dises mais la faire c'est que on a tout
d attirance ça donne qui en a qui
naissent avec une dette qui n'est ce pas
mais qui développe une en france pour
les enfants il y en a qui acte un
olympien n'a que non ouais il y en a qui
vont toute leur vie vont jamais été
mentionné par trimestre ils vont être
attirés par les enfants ne seront jamais
qu'ils vont vivre avec ça fait que puis
feront jamais rien non ici ça il y en a
il y en a plein pédophiles qu'on connaît
pas parce que c'est super tabou jamais
personne n'oserait se mais c'est sûr
j'en aux 6es jeux ceux qui ceux qui
attendaient depuis ça c'est dégueulasse
jamais jamais jamais je défendrai ça
mais je pense qu'il ya des pédophiles
que c'est vraiment triste pour qui que
ce pour ça que je sais que c'est
dégueulasse mais de trois des six sacs
en lice aussi horrible mais si on jamais
rien fait
cette position qui t'a fait pour ce
métier on peut dire des niaiseries après
on est on sait pas comment cerveau
marche exactement c'est petit c'est est
ce que ça peut soulager sauce que ça
exacerbe accepté mouche peu pour prendre
position là-dessus tout genre ce qu'il
ya autour des bulls et le film les
moyens aussi
ou est ce qu'il ya un pédophile qui est
là dedans puis a faim il est tellement
comme à cause que hoeness pression que
ce qui fait c'est dégueulasse qui fait
de ce coupé le pénis
il prend la décision de ce coupé le
pénis parce que sinon ils désirent
troll des erp il s'est d'abord c'est ici
que dans la société si un accès fiable
c'est impossible quand sa mère lui dit
pourquoi qui est s est pas de trouver
une fille les tournages mais j'aime poli
fille de mon âge ma main ces dégâts pour
nous mais il ya du monde qui mangent des
membres qui sont bandés
c'est vrai on a tout mon affaire qu'il
sait juste que mes jeux d'eau c'est vrai
je dois moi ça m'excite pas campi la
majorité mais quand ça va on paie
maintenant j'aimerais ça que vous
cherchiez un ebook est le pipe que vous
qui donnez moi que je vous rejoins des
rares mais mais non mais que ce soit ça
c'est un sujet qui est qui c'est intense
qui équitable ou vraiment pique-niqué
rire
on sait juste là j'imagine que ton père
de philippe piteux pas le droit de le
dire j'étais littéralement dans le
groupe d'humains le plus détesté de la
planète
ces dix pédophiles à quelqu'un que tout
de suite monté de aïn tout de suite tout
le monde était comestible s'était jamais
rien fait c'est pas de ta faute c'est
horrible tu peux pas dire ce que
quelqu'un va être là pour te réconforter
gens c'est j'imagine pauvres et sj j'ai
beaucoup de compassion cite jamais
confère évidemment sinon makeev sait on
sait maintenant on sait maintenant que
les attirances sexuelles les déserts
sont vraiment varié de personne en
personne un truc des trucs qui peuvent
te guérit sont complètement différentes
des fois ça peut être tellement
spécifiques de 73 des fois ça peut être
justement ce gag mais c'est faire un
gang bang sur le mont royal
ça c'est sûr qu'ils n'offrent juste il
n'y a rien d'autre tout haut que chaque
décor dans un lit ça fait rien et puis
après je te dis qu'est ce qu'on fait
avec le monde parce que leur désir comme
ceux les plus grandes pulsions sont
impossibles accompli
or tous et en plus si tu mets d'où ça
vient et il aimait tant qu'adjointe
mariage est tous arrivé moi parce que
c'est la pologne qui te dit non non mais
tu n'es pas avec l'arbitré gang bang
c'est sûr que c'est une construit sens
que toute sa vie il ya des arrangements
gosses et puis que le choc on a tout un
scénario interne de notre pornographie
parfaite
chaque fois qu'il ya un événement qui
nous arrive on rajoute un élément à
notre pornographie parfaite satisferait
tout mes besoins
c'est comme landreau peut être des galas
c'est dans ta tête c'est loin et
personne qu'il s'est lui la stib là
dessus on a tout plusieurs couches le
tout comme les normes et immonde
plusieurs coups non mais on a toutes les
sept partis le décaissement viscéral
s'ils ont tous le public le mettons tous
contents aussi quitté béton l'intime de
méthodes ph non mais vraiment de ce
métier tu es le genre des étoiles
alors là tout un petit look et qui est
montrable à quiconque
non c'est ce que tu penses que c'est le
sourire pour les drogues scapa totaux
d'abonnés vous pétez en vip après le
paquet on lit des voix en fait on fait
quarante mille pièces ne prochains mois
mais moi c'est vrai ça ouais tout le
monde sur un même titre garde mettant le
premier ministre surtout notre prévision
des arbres elle avoue qu'elle est venue
de qualité le tout premier ministre
quand je leur parle pas de goût on parle
on avait compris qu'aucun autre
référence pour cent un ipad à 300
milliards après sa censure la bouche la
plus chère non patchées james et sa
fille wikango bravo plein avec sa
boutique des familles font ça vraiment
dérangeante de québec ça bouge à ma
famille pour mon bien même en donner le
monde ont trouvé ça bizarre en fait que
j'ai comme un gp et je pense c'est quand
j'ai eu mon premier job
nous serons fixés à gauche a passé de
grave parce que ça compris je sais pas
ça comme tournées à quelque chose de
plus qu'est ce tu es et que c'était moi
je sais pas on s'est rapidement à ma vie
j'ai des becs sa bouche à ma famille
puis à manger j'ai vu un ami de mon père
de l'un avec sa bouche sont en fait que
des plus vieux que moi il devait avoir
25 ans j'avais comme ça je vous rappelle
me dit un coût de 25 ans
non pas que ça bouge à la sont pas ouais
parce qu'ils font encore maintenant si
qu'ils entonnent c'est comme dans leur
famille ces tarifs ont su je vais à dire
de quoi là ça va ce n'est vraiment dit
je me souviens je me suis trop d'enfants
pique ma maman donne des becs cissé a
beau jeter des petits becs ma maman le
halo des grosses grosses lèvres des
conserves angelina jolie style est ici
toutes les petits coussins en mousse des
réconfortant c'est ma petite maman c'est
que ce tube just et ma petite
mains sont pas aussi douce sont aussi
qu'est ce qu'on souhaitait lors de
l'épreuve les prochaines mois prochain
qu'est-ce que cantine m'entraîner sans
avoir besoin de quelqu'un ça j'aimerais
ça être capable je me lève et commence à
l'élite ce prof d'habitude une fois que
l'habitude il dit ça prend trois mois je
pense le quai une habitude de vraiment
de vienne en france commence à y aller
de ce principe ceux de l'api a mené sa
voix soit tout seul fait qu'ils aiment
et souhaité que manches à une langue
bien simple est sérieux sérieux l'idée
de faire des rencontres impromptues le
je pense que comme moi j'aimerais
beaucoup ça ne coûte rien
je pense oui moi je pense qu'au final on
serait content
tout le monde s'entend mieux qu'on pense
qu'ils vont s'entendre s'ils sont aussi
on évite mettons j'étais plus hippie
mettons richard martineau ce côté avec
françois lambert ajoutant n'aurait pas
mis notamment de belles rencontres
préfère mais oui et p&o beaudoin avec
les denis barbu ça serait bon barman
mais bon sang qu'est bo m'avait dit
qu'il avait trouvé ça drôle
fuck you je pense pas que la rancoeur je
pense que lui déteste complètement monde
est assurément des influenceurs ouais je
dis non mais tu vois je pense que lui
dire ils sont plus des faits mais moi je
te souhaite c'est des gardes de soi
disant des semble être une bonne place
je te souhaite de rester assise non
classé ouais moi aussi je te remercie
beaucoup de mes site est ouvert
c'est à dire à mon petit-fils et bien
c'est clair maintenant on va dire d'une
information confidentielle off aller au
salon une production du studio sf
[Musique]